unless you as a politically thinking
individual someone with passions and and
and opinions if you are not actively
pushing back defending say the Gadsden
flag it all gets erased and we are
moving now into that era where
you there are videos of people being
victimized and the victims get arrested
like you know that guy Daniel uh Penny I
think his name was in New York there's
Perry and Pena I want to confuse them
we're in that because
good men did nothing as the saying goes
and so the lazy uninterested people take
the path of least resistance now we see
it take form take the shape in police
departments the cops the cops are
looking at these mass lootings and these
robberies and they're like I can't deal
with that so what do they do nothing but
then when you are uh you know let's say
filing a legal challenge to an election
well the cops absolutely had no problem
doing their duties to arrest Donald
Trump